hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play holy crap
it's a monster and on today's episode of
holy crap it's a monster holy crap
there's monsters okay I actually
apologize because my recording failed
for some strange reason I don't know why
but I was backtracking to get the level
4 keypad I didn't cheat you can't say
that I cheated because I did not I did
not cheat and anyway there's the UH the
zombie virus is in there but there's
also uh radiation soup that I could get
that scared the bejesus out of me the
last time I saw it I swear
wait I can't oh yeah that's right ok
need to get rid of that put that on and
now I have a hazmat suit which I can use
for some friggin reason I don't know
what No thank you I do not want to
contract the disease I don't want the
doctor on my ass gone hey let me poke
you with my finger smell my finger Oh my
finger no I will not have none of that
and anyway I need to walk by six eight
two's containment area here he's still
stomping around the facility somewhere
but I'm not gonna worry about that
oh I also heard one seven three
skittering around here somewhere I just
don't know where oh and also some of you
said that ringing the cowbell was a dumb
idea well what do you think I am some
sort of badass Bing bong it don't do
nothing don't do nothing all bunch of
pansies it obviously doesn't do anything
okay so here let me build up my running
news hello computer okay here we go
nothing no whammies no whammies no
whammies no whammies goood okay so now
that we're through here I came over here
this is what this is about where the
recording failed I got here and it was
like Oh though okay I can't open it I
need a higher security clearance than
for
what well I am NOT gonna impede my
progress you son of a [ __ ] no hurt your
eyes there's a horrible monster don't
look oh it's so evil it's got horns and
fangs and three boobs oh it's so bad
okay
and uh I fought it off I punched in its
face and it went away your waters
evacuation shelter facility
if you say so buddy
oh look I've made it to thee why did my
camera just Dirk I don't have a code for
that unless it's on this torch note
which I know this is the different
sports note why do you keep jerking my
thing you're jerking my camera what is
it what what what what I'm light it's
what what huh
hey what are you talking about
buzz what so confused what just happened
what's with that lamp why is that lamb
special I guess it is kind of out of
place what's going on there that's new
what about that one no there must be
something secret up there hmm
how interesting and by interesting I
mean oh my god I want to get out of here
oh I hope he dies he's not gonna die but
I got a med kit and hazmat suit you're
fast you open doors quickly quicker than
I thought you scared me what the hell
what the hell like instant death why I'm
not gonna be able to get out of here I
don't have a you know what I'm going to
do something we should have done a long
time ago I'm going to spawn item card oh
my god Oh spawn item card spawn item key
card five spawn item Omni dammit they
changed everything
I guess I bought by owed don't kill me
bro don't kill me bro oh here you
anymore
haha stair job with all my kungfu skill
shot me who who shot me no one's here oh
no what dodged bob and weave
well good
what I what what what happened what
happened to me
I got Myrtle eyes I got Myrtle eyes they
shot me ten billion times why he holy
crap around them everyone ignore all the
cheating I've been doing because I
haven't been not cheating they're an
omni card in here least uh higher level
card
no there's nothing there's nothing I'm
not gonna get anything in there if I
can't get it ooh oh look at him go
quick like bunnies oh hi I'm an SCP now
I got my ass bath suit SCP ma RK i p li
ye are the most lethal SCP around
I'm not actually lethal I just like to
pop out of walls and go
they got annoyed at me popping out while
Lou
Blaine brain all over the walls
yeah then that was annoying well lotty
freaking da good for you you [ __ ]
you sons of [ __ ] I hate you no okay
I'm gonna wait till you go around this
time and then I'm gonna go this way to
get to God
yeah go so pro what no you don't see
nothing you don't see who I won't bother
you oh you're just gonna be hanging out
there there dick what you're just you're
in the wall you're [ __ ] you a-holes
you holes of it where'd you go did you
leave keep going you bastards
your clothes didn't close behind you nor
was it long okay you know what forget it
forget about forget about that hey look
it's gate B it's that gate that the
computer guy said that he would open
okay anyway was that what was that what
was that what did I just hear oh he's
down there don't do that to me oh I
gotta go down there oh my god this game
this particular episode wants to give me
ten million heart attacks
why you mother you heard me talking
about didn't you hear me talking about
didn't you nice tooth tooth that was
revenge for building your statue you oh
my god that was redonkulous what just
happened
Oh God
I can't even describe what the hell
happened there oh now it fell through
the floor god damn it goddamn it ah he's
not supposed to be able to do that and
he did it anyway he's out of a bit oh my
god oh oh okay alright I'm okay I'm
hoping that this this will be good maybe
if I can get if I do fall through the
floor again I'm gonna noclip as fast as
I can and then get out of there I can
get this ah be fine fine probably all
the noclipping that I was doing so we
got to go around him cuz there's no
other way there's no other way around
him except for doing this cuz their sons
a [ __ ] yeah that's right March on toy
soldiers like closes god stop it stop
startling me I don't like it I don't
like it okay a 1 7 3 is down there it's
being as usual dick South I didn't even
see it's so dark did it am I wearing
I'm not wearing the gas mask it's so
dark am I wearing the hazmat suit no I
am NOT it is so dark I cannot see
usually I can see down there where he be
but I cannot see stop it stop it you
dick don't come through here
we're come through here oh my god wait
are they wash take care of won 7-3 don't
kill 1 7 3 please 1 7 3 come on dude
well 1 7 3 is right down there why don't
you do your job and contain him today
them contain him what that was cowbell
man wasn't it you know what you know
what I'm sick of this I think it was I'm
sick of being scared every single time I
turn around going to go I'm just gonna
go I'm going up I'm going nope
I hear you in there you dick you dick
what's that frustrated you can't get to
me you can't come through here right won
7-3 would snap his neck like a twig
right right
oh yeah are they oh yeah they call out
when they blink so that they can not die
that's really cool I wish I could suit
wait I want to see this I don't want to
see this wanna see this
whoa where's mr. Bing bong Bell oh wow
that's so cool look what's happening
what's happening that's so cool
I think it's stuck in a loop though whoa
does that mean I can dick with them hey
buddies oh god no shut up look at the
guy blinking oh no don't Blake blinking
blinking Oh God
why can't I move oh okay I messed up
numerous times there what was that oh
god he's coming oh god I closed my eyes
I actually go by as I had no idea where
he was
oh oh I'm out of there oh I'm so out
about about about I'm out I'm out I'm
out
oh god stop working my stopped working
my thing oh so out I'm so out
I'm so out so I blink yeah blink you
bastards oh I don't even know was the
anomalous duck I don't even have the
comfort of the anomalous duck anymore oh
there he is
rarity
okay anyway I'm all out of time and I
don't want to play anymore
for now anyway I'll get back to it later
but Susie yeah okay don't thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
I got sick
just gotta get home right I gotta get to
my fan what I'm doing